Let's go next to our caller from the six one
nine area code.
If we can, who's calling today from six one
nine.
What does that mean?
That's you.
Okay, perfect.
Um, I was calling because I was, um, I had
a question about, uh, that you could see monitored
demonic to take the monetization of youtube
demonetization.
Yes.
It's difficult.
[inaudible]
okay.
So, um, are we, and then, uh, can we agree
that the reason why mainstream media doesn't
talk about certain topics is because they
don't want to offend their advertisers?
Um, would that be a fair assessment?
I think as a general principle, there is no
doubt that there is a influence in terms of
what you do and don't see on corporate media
based on the whims of advertisers.
Sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Perfect.
So why would it be any different for you?
To,
what do you mean?
Tell me more about what you mean.
Okay.
So if, if mainstream media doesn't talk about
certain topics because they don't want to
offend your advertisers, why wouldn't you
to feel the same way?
Like, okay, these left is, are offending corporations
that are advertising with us, right?
They shut them down.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
No, you're completely right.
I mean, that's the whole problem.
Youtube started out as one thing and now it's
basically becoming through these monetization
policies.
It's basically becoming just like corporate
media and in fact, it's mostly legacy corporate
media channels that have a youtube presence
that are being propped up by youtube.
I completely agree.
It's becoming exist.
The reason it would be different is because
youtube started as something very different.
But listen, it was bought by Google.
It's become huge.
It's influenced in many of the same ways that
corporate media is.
So you're completely right.
It's basically become like corporate media.
So, so my, what's the w so what do we do moving
forward?
Because I, I saw the idea of a union, a Youtube
Union being propped up, but it Kinda got shut
down by other youtubers.
So I'm just, I'm concerned like, so what,
what, what should we do moving forward?
Best thing to do is fund the shows that you
like directly because that makes them, uh,
not have to worry about what it is that's
happening with monetization.
You'd, youtube did do one thing.
Youtube, uh, Youtube CEO recently said in
a list of all sorts of stuff, much of which
is not great.
She said it's really important for people
to be able to upload whatever they want to
youtube, assuming it's not illegal.
So that's great.
As long as you can upload whatever you want
to Youtube.
If your audience is funding you directly and
you don't have to rely on youtube monetization,
that's the best path forward to be quite honest.
And it's the most reliable one as well.
[inaudible] all right.
Thank you David.
All right, I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.
Let's go next to our caller from the five
one six area code.
Who's calling today from five one six.